[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette dernière édition de l'année
de parlement hebdo on va refaire
ensemble la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec à mes côtés kathia
gilder bonjour katia bonjour oriane et
nous accueillons aujourd'hui racheté mal
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes sénateur socialiste du val
d'oise et vous n'êtes pas être premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste par
intérim on peut dire ça comme ça ce qui
compte c'est de plus parce qu'ils soient
présents et travail eh bien vous êtes là
en tout cas dans l'actualité qu'on va
revoir avec vous le vote du budget le
vote final du budget à l'assemblée les
députés ont eu le dernier mot sur le
projet doit après l'échec la procédure
de conciliation avec les sénateurs le
bilan législatif des premiers mois du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron des
réformes menées au pas de charge mais
presque toutes adopté la politique
migratoire du gouvernement divise au
sein même de la majorité une circulaire
de gérard collomb sème le trouble et on
va commencer par le budget à 2018 qui
après trois mois de débats intenses au
parlement était adoptée cette semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier budget du quinquennat macron
adopté cette semaine au parlement
l'assemblée nationale a eu le dernier
mot sur le texte faute d'accord avec les
sénateurs budget adopté sous les
critiques de l'opposition de droite
comme de gauche qui dénonce un budget
pour les riches rabhi cas
qui est contre donc le projet de loi de
finances pour 2008 et adopté un ultime
vote à main levée pour boucler le projet
de loi de finances 2010 lors faute
d'accord avec les sénateurs c'est
l'assemblée nationale qui a eu le
dernier mot sur ce budget le ministre et
le rapporteur du texte se félicite d'un
budget qu'il juge favorable pour les
classes moyennes je pense bien entendu à
l'ensemble des parlementaires
de la majorité comme de l'opposition du
sénat comme de la semaine nationale et
particulièrement ceux qui amendement
après amendement article après article
ont contribué à faire de ce budget un
budget de transformation au service du
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens et
qui libère l'énergie des entreprises
certains jugés intenables l'équation
budgétaire est impossible la mise en
oeuvre d'un programme et notamment de
notre programme présidentiel le retour
du déficit sous la barre des 3% semblait
compromis j'observe que le climat a
changé les promesses ont été tenues nous
avons engagé la première étape de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation un
impôt injuste territorialement et
socialement la france insoumise qui
depuis six mois dénoncé un budget pour
les riches a tenté un dernier baroud
d'honneur en déposant deux motions en
séance elles ont toutes les deux été
rejeté le budget que vous nous avez
présenté que vous êtes en passe
d'adopter et le budget des ultra riches
parce que vous pourrez toujours
faire agir vos calculateur vos machines
à calculer de manière
différente vous apercevrez toujours que
ceux qui vont le plus profité de ce
budget sont les 1 % des français les
plus riches qui vont capter une très
grande partie de vos cadeaux fiscaux ce
premier budget du quinquennat contient
deux mesures phares mais controversé la
transformation de l'essai en impôts sur
la seule fortune immobilière et la fin
progressive de la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des ménages comment vous qualifier
ce premier budget de là un maquereau est
ce que vous parlez vous aussi de budget
pour les riches l'image restera je crois
que c'est l'image de ce début de
quinquennat et je crois que les français
loin sivu c'est en tout cas le budget de
la vérité des prix on nous avait dit et
à de droite et de gauche et je le dis
c'est comme l'impressionnisme là il ya
le bugue le le tableau complet quand
même sur l' isf et d'autres côtés sur
les appelle pas qu'on sexe la même chose
donc et vous avez vu l'étude de l'insee
qui montre bien que le pouvoir d'achat
des français va diminuer sensiblement
avec ce budget là donc moi je ne suis
pas favorable ce budget quand vous dites
pour les plus riches lisf d'une part la
flat tax même sur les actions la
taxation va diminuer par contre pour les
autres la cg supplémentaires par contre
l'appel quand vous ratez sur la pl c'est
un vrai problème aujourd'hui on fait des
cadeaux fiscaux pas de mesures de
correctifs qui donnerait un peu des
marqueurs de gauche à ce but et mon
problème c'est pas des marques lors de
gauche et c'est socialement juste est-ce
qu'il est socialement juste mais un
budget c'est pas juste encore une fois
on prend telle ou telle mesure c'est à
dire dans sa globalité
aujourd'hui vous êtes une famille
française vous allez avoir la cje en
plus si vous êtes dans un logement
social et beaucoup de nous construire le
son ça va vous coûter plus cher parce
que lorsqu'on oublie de dire c'est
qu'elle a toujours pas d'accord sur
l'appel est donc la moitié des français
qui touche la pelle sont dans le parc
privé ne rompt pas cette fameuse baisse
et pour ceux qui sont dans le parc
social on en train d'affaiblir les
soutes hlm qui ne pourront ni
reconstruire ni entretenir c'est quand
même c'est quand même encore une fois
c'est une mécanique alors sur la
procédure ya eu presque trois mois de
débats budgétaires intense un passage au
parlement notamment chez vous au sénat
et finalement au final le texte adopté
semble être quasiment le même que le
texte initialement présenté par le
gouvernement est ce que c'est la
victoire du pouvoir exécutif sur le
législateur en tout cas ça pose problème
sur la conception qu'a ce pouvoir de ce
qu'est la démocratie vous l'avez vu sur
les syndicats rien à dire puisque les
ordonnances qui étaient proposés ont été
appliquées sans quasiment 1
avec aussi la démocratie des élus donc
la démocratie et lui parle pas vous
voyez bien la conférence des territoires
les les collectivités refusent les
accords proposés qui sont pas
acceptables hélas au parlement ont dit
trois mois mais à la fin rien n'est
changé enfin c'est un problème de
conception démocratique donc c'est un
budget qui effectivement un budget où la
vérité des prix c'est que ce
gouvernement là n'est pas sûr de gens
voulaient que sur une jambe droite il à
cloche-pied sur la jambe droite et de
l'autre côté il ya un problème de
démocratie de fonctionnement les
salaires nous renvoie la question la
fameuse réduction du nombre de
parlementaires que moi je souhaite des
parlementaires pour qu'ils aient du
pouvoir qu'ils puissent succès lors du
jour qui plus imposer un son de texte ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui sous
calmants la même
institut alizés on restait sur ce budget
si tu es mal les groupes parlementaires
de gauche à l'assemblée ont déposé un
recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel sur ce texte qu'est ce
que vous allez faire au sénat est ce que
vous y réfléchissez donc ça s'est fait
hier soir et donc nous avons prévu
d'échanger mois pour le parti didier
guillaume pour le groupe au sénat et
allié fort donc nous allons dans les
prochaines heures pour une décision
commune donc on a donc comme nous
l'avait dit ça a été adopté par
l'assemblée donc ils ont annoncé cela en
lien avec nous et puis là on va
travailler ensemble ne le sait ne groupe
d'ailleurs je j'associe également le
groupe des parlementaires européens nous
sommes 120 parlementaires nous sommes la
première force de gauche l'opposition à
ce pouvoir est à la droite avec wauquiez
qui vient d'être installé et donc nous
travaillons ensemble moi je vais est ce
que nous travaillons ensemble sur les
prises de position ce que nous faisons
et ce que nous allons faire alors les
travaux parlementaires sont suspendus
jusqu'au 15 janvier c'est l'occasion
rachid t'es mal d'un petit bilan des
premiers mois d'activité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis l'élection des manuels macro il
semble que le parlement travaille à un
rythme soutenu petit tour d'horizon de
ces premiers mois de législature au
sénat d'abord avec céline 6 ou des
réformes au pas de charge depuis qu
emmanuel macron est président les
sénateurs n'ont pas chômé louane
moralisation réforme du code du travail
lutte contre le terrorisme et budget si
tous ces textes ont bien été modifié par
la haute assemblée aucun n'a été rejeté
en bloc ni par la droite ni par la
gauche socialiste c'est pas une
opposition systématique ni habits ni oui
c'est la position du sénat est
traumatique et encore une fois dire la
vérité on n'est pas suivi par rapport à
ce que fait le gouvernement on est
critique mais on n'est pas non plus dans
une opposition systématique qu'on essaye
de dire quand c'est ça nous paraît bien
un excédent plongeon de ce qui a été
fait mais qui me paraît satisfaire ce
dont on a besoin dans ce pays et ne soit
pas être content systématiquement pour
certain emmanuel macron bénéficie encore
d'un état de grâce à l'avenir les
relations pourraient se corser avec le
sénat vingt ans plus facile au début du
mandat sauf que je pense qu'il eût fallu
changer les méthodes y compris de
travailler avec le parlement pour les
temps plus durs qui viennent forcément
parce qu'au bout de six mois ou d'un an
le côté d'un grâce se dissout si vous
n'avez pas mis en place un système
relationnel
plus
korek plus facile avec les oppositions
ou tim hudak vous avez des oppositions
plus brutale le groupe communiste qui a
pour le moment rejetée la plupart des
textes critiques la méthode macron trop
rapide je pense que si vous voulez c'est
une façon d'avancer vite pour justement
faire passer des réformes négative et de
ne pas permettre à
tous ceux qui sont opposés à ces choix
là de pouvoir se rassembler de pouvoir
vite réagir un point de convergence
entre tous les groupes politiques
le sénat est devenu en six mois la
chambre d'écho de la colère des élus
locaux et le lieu de défense des
collectivités territoriales thème quelle
maison vous faites vous de ces premiers
mètres d'agis la thur au sénat est ce
que le sénat était l'illustration de
l'opposition constructive
pour notre parti le parent solide nous
sommes dans l'opposition et moi je n'ai
pas de qualificatifs parce que je le
rappelle est dans l'opposition et dans
un régime démocratique c'est vouloir
améliorer pouvoir s'opposer et pouvoir
même voté donc pas de faux débats entre
nous nous sommes dans l'opposition et
donc au sénat nous travaillons sur le
budget nous n'étions pas favorables et
donc si nous avions pu voter le budget
nous aurons tous les est entendue est ce
que vous pensez vous êtes assez entendu
position est assez intense et je pense
d'ailleurs pas que l'opposition je
reviens c'est ce qui est même ce
gouvernement le choix du prénom unique
c'est de dire tout ça et on le
parlementaire tout ça n'est pas très
intéressant regardez bien vous l'avez
dit sur le budget qui quand même et le
texte phare d'une mandature fin d'une
session pardon de chaque année ou sur
d'autres textes il n'y a pas de
modification je voyais une fois une
émission où il y avait pourtant le
président du groupe du modem qui est
membre de la majorité et il avait du mal
expliqué un amendement déposé est votée
par la majorité donc quand vos
parlementaires ne sont même pas écouté
vous imaginez bien sûr l'opposition et
donc c'est une conception cas le prix un
public je pense que c'est un retour aux
années 60 voilà où il ya un seul lieu de
pouvoir une recentralisation et comme
vous le disiez dans votre reportage moi
je vois sur le terrain gelé les élus
locaux sont pas contents parce que ce
sont qui au quotidien font vivre ce qui
est le pacte républicain qui investir
pour l'avenir qui peuvent assurer un son
de service on leur dit quoi vous coûter
trop cher de populisme en fait vous
allez on va vous réduire vos capacités
d'action et vous serez toujours en
première ligne face aux habitants est ce
que ça veut dire que les relations se
corsait dans les mois à venir entre le
parlement et l'exécutif
moi j'en appelle le
l'exécutif à entendre il ya comprendre
ce qu'est une démocratie comme la nôtre
c'est qu'il faut construire il faut
accepter le débat il faut accepter la
critique il faut accepter les corps
intermédiaires qui sont là pour faire
vivre la cité française je pense qu'un
preuve de méthode parce que une approche
différente que nous avons donc voilà
donc c'est un débat est donc nous nous
restons au parlement déterminée fort de
nos valeurs phares du mandat que nous
ont donné nos électeurs et donc j'en
appelle aux vraiment parce que vous
savez bien que déjà dans la vème
république on va dire qu'il ya une
équipe des pouvoirs mais alors là pour
le coup c'est poussé à son paroxysme
pendant ces six mois plusieurs réformes
majeures ont été lancés ont été votés
pardon parlement d'autres sont lancés
revue de détail avec stéphanie des
pierres
depuis six mois les députés ne chôme pas
les projets de lois s'enchaînent au pas
de charge premier texte du quinquennat
la loi pour la confiance dans la vie
politique votée début août c'était l'un
des engagements des manuels macron pour
tenter de restaurer la confiance entre
élus et citoyens
après la pause estivale le rythme est
effréné et tant pis si les nouveaux
députés ont du mal à suivre
début octobre l'assemblée adopte le
projet de loi antiterroriste pour
transposer dans le droit commun
certaines dispositions en vigueur sous
l'état d'urgence il fallait le voter
avant le 1er novembre date de sortie de
l'état d'urgence autre réforme
emblématique celle du code du travail
le gouvernement a choisi de légiférer
par ordonnance le parlement les a
ratifié fin novembre si l'opposition n'a
pas réussi à mobiliser massivement
contre les ordonnances dans la rue dans
l'hémicycle la france insoumise et les
communistes s'imposent comme les
premiers opposants emmanuel macron ya
entre nous
un affrontement sévère qui c'est qui
s'est nouée et qui va se poursuivre
parce que nous on va pas lâcher la faire
non plus voilà donc je crois que cette
majorité elle a mené une politique
antisociale une politique de droite une
politique libérale une politique au
service de la finance tout l'automne les
députés ont planché sur le budget un
marathon comme chaque année mais comme
c'est le premier projet de loi de
finance du quinquennat macron il donne
le ton de sa politique économique le
texte emblématique je pense que c'est
notre premier budget le premier budget
parce que c'est le bij et dans lequel on
a revalorisé mieux bs la location du
point de cape et auquel on a par le
plfss redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français et sur leur fiche de paye en
janvier en septembre ils le verront
immédiatement la même façon qu'ils
verront qu' une grande partie d'entre
eux ne paieront pas la taxe d'habitation
ou 30 % d'entre elles dès le mois de
septembre 2018 et ça pour le coup c'est
une promesse qu'on avait faite sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui est immédiate qui se
traduit dans la vie des français l'année
2010 8 s'annonce tout aussi intense au
programme la loi sur l'immigration la
réforme de la procédure pénale une
nouvelle loi logement et tout un
ensemble de textes économiques et
sociaux notamment pour réformer la
formation professionnelle et l'assurance
chômage alors en quelques moyens quand
même beaucoup de textes qui sont passés
au parlement voté un peu au pas de
charge dit certains est-ce que vous
comme vos collègues députés vous parlez
de burnout vous êtes en épuisement face
à tous ces textes qui arrive sans arrêt
leur choix ce sont les députés la plus
qu'en marche qui disent cela
donnons nous travaillons là dessus mais
comme tout nouveau gouvernement ya une
volonté dire regardez on fait en fait il
n'y a pas de réforme au pas de charge
mais si regardez pas prendre des
exemples concrets sur le droit du
travail nous avons contesté nous
contestons toujours cette approche là
puisque ce texte loi là pardon enlève
des protections salariés en l'aide du
dialogue social et non n'apporte rien en
terme de développement économique donc
c'est de la précarité pour tous si vous
prenez le opale il parlait tout à
l'heure du budget je rappelle que pour
l'hôpital c'est moins 10 milliards que
faisait la joie et à augmenter par
exemple le forfait hospitalier je
pourrais prendre d'autres exemples d'eau
ils ont travaillé
sans pouvoir mettre en avant les
parlementaires l'appliquant marche que
ce soit au sénat ou à l'assemblée donc
moi je souhaite un parlement matures
kiko construisent la loi ces différences
fondamentales en même temps on regarde
que la cote de popularité de d'emmanuel
macro on voit qu'elle est à ses hôtes
selon plusieurs instituts de sondage
donc ça veut dire quelque part qu'il a
raison de vouloir maintenir ce rythme là
et sa cote même augmente chez les
sympathisants socialistes nous dit un
dernier sondage bva pour la tribune
comment vous interpréter cette tendance
moi j'ai bien noté mme c chaque candidat
les surprises aux 7-10 je regarde pas
les sondages et puis d'où ils vivent pas
armé vous voulez je ne sais que dans
l'électorat de droite ya une vraie
profession des domaines macro mais en
mettant dans le même sondage vous notez
bien qu'une majorité français dix sept
président des riches il ya une forme de
contradiction ce qui m'importe c'est moi
ce que j'entends sur le terrain et ce
que je vois comme texte donc il faut
attendre encore vous devant moi je peux
pas attendre je marche je sais que les
caractériser tout de suite que c'était
ce régime là ce pouvoir là je les dis
est sûre encore une fois quand vous
supprimez les sf et en même temps vous
baissez la pl enfin tout est dit vous
dévoilez votre politique c'est ça en
tout cas on sait que votre politique
elle est effectivement sur le versant
droite alors cette semaine agitée mal il
ya une polémique sur un autre sujet
sensible la politique migratoire du
gouvernement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'origine du tumulte une sûr qu'une
circulaire datée du 12 décembre qui
autorise les services de l'état à se
rendre dans les centres d'hébergement
pour recenser les migrants mardi à
l'assemblée une députée de la majorité
elle rêve a interpellé le ministre de
l'intérieur très tôt le président de la
république a fixé notre philosophie sur
l'accueil des étrangers plus d'humanité
et de dignité les centres de rétention
deviennent des centres de détention et
sont 1,6 milliard de notre république
pourriez vous monsieur le ministre nous
détailler les équilibres politiques de
votre réforme une réforme sont posture
et son préjugé alors que voulons-nous
faire avec le président de la république
une politique équilibrée et ce matin
j'ai accueilli trente personnes
originaires du darfour et d'erythrée qui
étaient des réfugiés et effectivement
nous disons que nous allons demain faire
la guerre aux passeurs et cela nous le
faisons avec tous les pays d'afrique et
tous les pays d'europe qui ne veulent
pas effectivement de passeurs à travers
leurs frontières machete man vous avez
demandé vous le retrait de cette
circulaire pourquoi alors je demande
effectivement seront très au nom du
parti sa liste pour une raison simple on
touche à l'essentiel là on est sur des
hommes et des femmes des enfants qu'on
doit héberger on est sur des questions
d'hébergement d'urgence d'ailleurs je
note le préampli cabane on sait que plus
personne ne serait dehors avant le 31
décembre 2017 ou nous semblent tous
l'oublier donc je reviens l'essentiel
c'est l'hébergement de cession de crise
extrême des hommes et des femmes des
enfants dehors donc il faut pouvoir leur
mettre sur le lin d'un toit sur la tête
et là on nous annonce
que on va en plus faire du tri ont mis
le tout ça va excusez moi c'est quand
même assez bizarre vous qualifier cette
politique migratoire mais c'est pas une
petite migratoire d'ailleurs parce que
via un texte en préparation et on dit
des bâtons débattre allemands venus
disposition est ce déjà entendu la
réponse du pont du ministre c'est pas
une question des passeurs lamballe
d'hommes et de femmes que nous
hébergeons
pour avoir un minimum de dignité dans le
pays à mesure dans le pays des droits de
l'homme ces mesures sont scandaleuses le
tri il ya une forme de flicage on va
dire qu'ils quittent ces se forme de
recensement appelons ça comme on veut et
ce qu'on allait donc nous avons demandé
retrait d'ailleurs pas seulement nous
les associations également qui
travaillent au quotidien
et on peut pas avoir ce message là et en
même temps pour reprendre l'expression
chère aux prêts à appliquer être à
bruxelles et d'annoncer qu'il faut
accueillir encore des migrants disent
que respecter donc ces deux discours et
en même temps peut pas dire qu'on n'a
pas un prêt avec l'autriche et quand
nous interrompt parce que vous avez
parlé de la députée nous avons aussi
interrogé le ministre sur ces questions
là mais sur la question de l'autriche
par exemple et qu'on nous dit ce que je
rappelle l'autriche allemand d'extrême
droite y est qu'un de loterie gagnant
non mais c'est pas que trois miss bryan
chiu vice chancelier en plus mais ce
n'est pas qu'un problème de non c'est
que fondamentalement vous avez vous avez
l'autre extrême droite qui dirige un
pays en europe et donc qui va présider
le conseil de l'europe à partir du 1er
juillet nous demandons comme elle fait
en son temps jacques chirac et lionel
jospin de refuser cela et qu'est-ce que
nous répondons également jugeons surratt
mais moi je leur réponds quand il a
fallu entre les deux tours
assurer la démocratie voter pour une
mâcon contre le front national nous
n'avions pas attendu les actes bar
principe tandis que
l'extrême droite on s'y habitue et en
tout cas il faut arrêter de courir après
des fois assumer ce que nous sommes
c'est ce que fait c'est ce que fait
manuel mac moi
je fais je dis juste que je suis surpris
qu'ils n'interviennent pas sur
l'autriche et je suis très surpris de
cette approche cette étude sur la
question des migrants et donges là
encore une fois de ce dont on parle
c'est de voir un côté recensement des
migrants alors que là ce moment là quand
on aurait le d'hébergement c'est la
dignité humaine et ce sont les valeurs
fondamentales autres pays qui sont henri
ce que vous pensez qu'il va rester sur
cette ligne vu que edouard philippe
annonce qu avait de grandes
consultations à partir de du mois de
janvier sur ces questions je pense que
le premier ce doit être réfléchie se
rendre d'abord il faut suspendre
circulaire demandant le retrait mais au
moins s'ils pouvaient faire un pas le
relaxe ne soit pas mis un terme à une
mise en pratique et puis cette
consultation effectivement mais je lui
dis il faut aussi associer les forces
qui sont au parlement
c'est aussi ça la démocratie les
associations qui bosse et je les
remercie
parce qu'on sait tous qu elles font au
quotidien toute l'année toute l'année et
en même temps faire en sorte que les
partis et des associations à qui on a
aujourd'hui retiré la capacité des
parlementaires d'aidés via les via les
réserves parlementaires faut jamais
oublier que tout ça est un ensemble on
va maintenant passer un tout autre sujet
réciter mal l'actualité du parti
socialiste avec notre partenaire du
figaro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour en parler on accueille sur ce
plateau sur le sapin bonjour charles
bonjour bonjour rachid tu es mal alors
les divisions et les prises de position
individuelles eux continuent au parti
socialiste on va prendre un exemple vous
venez d'en parler vous avez actée dans
un communiqué votre opposition à cette
circulaire collomb sur le recensement
des migrants ce qui n'a pas empêché une
dizaine de responsables socialistes de
partager un déjeuner politique avec
gérard collomb place beauvau on peut
prendre un autre exemple vous avez acté
le fait que vous soyez dans l'opposition
emmanuel macron dès l'été ce qui n'a pas
empêché certains caciques du parti
notamment le président ps du groupe au
sénat de défendre le contraire vous êtes
coordinateur du ps mais les socialistes
sont ils vraiment cordes coordonnables
ils le sont et en tout cas moi qui était
hier soir à bordeaux et la veille à à
belfort je sais ce que je pense des
militants c'est qui a besoin de
collectif à la fois de présenter une
vision de ce que nous sommes pour les
français français démontrer l'utilité du
parti sa liste après la défaite
historique que nous avons connue et donc
il faut pour cela travailler et score de
d après si je peux me permettre sur la
question on peut pas mélanger les choses
que quelques personnes et son talent et
un dîner ou un déjeuner je ne sais plus
je crois pas qu'ils aient de
responsables socialistes de premier rang
qui était en tout cas voilà et sur la
question du fait que nous sommes dans
l'opposition so ferme à pas et je vous
le précise c'est partagé par les
socialistes et didier guillaume que vous
c'est n'a pas défendu vraiment
c'est pas ça le dédit nous sommes pas je
pense thématique systématique donc voilà
donc je pense encore une fois ce qui a
manqué dans le dernier quinquennat c'est
du collectif et moi là où je suis ma
responsabilité c'est de créer du
collectif de coordonnées mais je vous
assure que par exemple sur le travail
que nous faisons ensemble les
socialistes au parlement et le parti sur
la question la formation professionnelle
ce que nous allons faire sur la
fonctionnelle au nous travaillons sont
on parle du congrès socialiste stable
oui tout à fait alors vous venez de le
rappeler le parti socialiste est dans
l'opposition les appétits au sein du
parti socialiste et ghz à la proche du
congrès qui aura lieu les 7 et 8 avril
prochains et qui désignera la prochaine
tête
du parti il y à un ancien ministre qui
ne cache pas son intérêt pour le poste
occupé il ya encore il ya peu de temps
par jean christophe cambadelis c'est
stéphane le foll mais pour incarner le
parti socialiste alors qu on a été élus
députés grâce au soutien de la
république en marche quand on est un
parti d'opposition est ce pas
problématique vous êtes en train
d'essayer de faire jaser la politique
politicienne moi mon souci du congrès
c'est d'abord et avant tout deux pâles
aux françaises et aux français est dur
et on a digéré ce pays on a des valeurs
on fait des choses sur les territoires
bon maintenant c'est à nous de vous
présenter une vision de la société notre
projet et c'est ça l'enjeu majeur et
puis après il faut des gens qui
refont le parti qui dirige le parti une
équipe et une personnalité tout ça c'est
un collectif donc moi je ne suis pas sûr
les petites phrases justes pas sur les
personnes et toutes celles et tous ceux
militants responsables qui souhaitent
travailler à la refondation de par sa
liste sont les bienvenus les bienvenus
et puis après c'est notre parti on
commencera par les idées et on finit par
les hommes et les femmes donc cette
demande est il justement le temps des
idées parlons-en vous venez de terminer
un cycle
sur les ateliers de la refondation pour
nourrir d'idées de propositions le parti
sauf que du fond il y en a plein les
tiroirs rue de solférino un exercice à
peu près analogue avait été lancé il y a
que quelques mois avec outre les livrets
de là les cahiers de la présidentielle
délivré thématiques avec des centaines
d'heures des changes avec des
universités des experts j'ai questionné
les différents candidats à la primaire
de la gauche aucun n'a pris le temps de
les lire qu'est ce qui nous assure que
ce travail de fond que vous défendez
elle n'aura pas le même destin alors
d'abord les candidats que vous aviez
interrogés nous ont pas répondu je
rappelle que si je prends par exemple le
le nous avions déjà dans l'allée dans
lesquelles la précède le revenu de base
oui il devient été repris et je peux
citer d'autres exemples d'autres raisons
les forums de la refondation que nous
menons et qui vont se poursuivre c'est
quoi ces amendes et de désir bon nous
avons pris une défaite historique est-ce
qu'il faut pas se poser deux minutes
comme n'importe qui peut le faire nous
sommes à terre comment nous relever
d'abord en regardant ce qui s'est passé
en nous interrogeant sur nos valeurs en
parlant avec les françaises et les
français c'est ce que nous menons et si
nous n'avions pas fait ça vous dirait
prenez temps de la réponse mais nous
prenons ce temps là et nous aurons un
congrès le 7 et 8 avril et les
socialistes sont toujours là sont bien
relevés et vont continuer eh bien ce
sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
agité mal d'avoir été notre invité merci
charles satin fou c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve en 2018 pour une
nouvelle année riche en politique et en
actualité parlementaire et en attendant
les équipes de public sénat et lcp
assemblée nationale vous souhaite à tous
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année
[Musique]